en peu de temps nous sommes devenus de
grands consommateurs de vin au point où
même les tablettes d'épicerie déborde de
bouteilles remplies avec des vins du
monde entier est actuellement des
québécois travaille très fort pour se
faire une place dans cette offre
grandissante des centaines d'amateurs de
vin sont présents au salon de la grande
dégustation pour venir essayer les
derniers crus ici des grands vins
côtoient les fins connaisseurs
ici par contre aucun vin d'épicerie
pourtant les ventes de vins d'épicerie
ont le vent dans les voiles
une bouteille sur trois et vendus en
épicerie un marché de plus de 300
millions de dollars
achetez vous des vins à l'épicerie
à l'occasion oui ou java des parle de
coûts et du temps que j'ai si j'ai pas
le temps d'aller à la saq jeu les pandas
l'épicerie mais là il commence à avoir
beaucoup de choix les publics récemment
j'ai acheté but pour la nouvelle
collection but j'ai parcouru la france
il y a de bonnes chances que les
bouteilles vendues proviennent des
nouvelles têtes d'affiché des épiceries
comme la sommelière jessica harnois je
voulais te démocrate il vint je voulais
que le vin soit accessible pour tout le
monde parce que moi même
à quand j'allais en épicerie j'ai
acheter de la bière et j'adore la bière
mais j'avais pas une offre produit qui
répondait à mes besoins
donc voilà but est arrivé la sommelière
prévoyait vendre autour de 400 mille
bouteilles
elle en a vendu plus de 2 millions et
les soutenu par arte rat un géant du vin
au canada campagne de marketing à la
télé et sur le web
dégustations dans les centres
commerciaux présentoirs soigneusement
placé au point de vente
le sommelier de réputation
internationale françois chartier a
flairé lui aussi la bonne affaire en
proposant sa gamme de vins harmonie sais
je suis à l'ispa j'avais une certaine
confiance que je pouvais amener quelque
chose devant que les gens seraient allés
coûte donc il ya un changement de
schmoll seul lyon il ya là il ya quatre
cinq nouveaux joueurs dans le dé ka ka
mandé chose intéressant nouveaux joueurs
mais aussi des marques maison métro avec
ses vins hémisphère cosco et 6,20 qu'un
clown iga avec la gamme wish for plus de
choix donc et de l'espace tablette qui
ne cesse d'augmenter
alors il doit y avoir un intérêt parce
que l'on voit de plus en plus des
vieilles maisons mind
oui absolument des vins de marque privée
ça fait déjà quelques années on a surfé
la gamme ministère pour sa comprennent
très bien le client apprécie pouvoir
mettre une ou deux bouteilles dans leur
panier à mesure qu'ils font leurs
emplettes pour planifier les repas
qu'ils vont faire durant la semaine
parce qu'elles soient pas que le côté
pratique hostile de la chose
et tu est essentielle dans un contexte
le web pour rappel par toyota depuis un
an
la loi a changé à l'avantagé du
consommateur première évolution
on peut en fait acheter des vins du
québec dans les épiceries et les
dépanneurs deuxième révolution on
retrouve maintenant plus d'informations
sur les bouteilles
la variété des raisins qu'on a nos
cépages peut maintenant être inscrite
tout comme le mil is in hell et vous
remarqué que maintenant les cépages sont
sur les bouteilles oui oui trouver sa
place oui mais ce qui ne change pas
c'est que mis à part les vins du québec
les produits vendus en épicerie sont
obligatoirement des vins en vrac c'est à
dire des vins importés en citerne est
embouteillée ici est ce que le sa vie qu
ici en épicerie ce sont des vaillants
brac qu'on valait en bouteille au québec
ah ouais moi je dis c'est souvent là les
épiceries a souvent cédé pic est bon il
y en a qui vont nous dire ce pauvre est
et pas de quête non beaucoup de vins là
en épicerie cd pigasse c'est pas bon
d'après le journaliste spécialisé en
vins marc andré gagnon
le principal défaut du vin d'épicerie
c'est le fait que ce soit du vin en vrac
fait de façon industrielle dont les vins
en bouteilles sont des vins fait par des
vignerons qui pensent être fédérer en
qualité
ils vont essayer d'utiliser aussi le
moins de produits chimiques que possible
sur les vins de meilleure qualité
bon mais pour la production va que c'est
très différent parce qu'on vise en vrac
c'est la quantité non pas la qualité et
on essaie de vendre peu cher le vin en
vrac est une industrie de milliards de
dollars on y transitent chaque jour des
milliers
litres de vin souvent à aussi peu qu'un
dollar le litre
ils sont ensuite assemblés par des
multinationales qui créent des marques
comme on lance des vêtements de
prêt-à-porter le consommateur il sait
pas c'est pas que 20 qui achètent le cas
nous savoir marquer château un tel essai
pas que château un tel n'existe même pas
c'est un nom c'est un non tout
simplement quand on a de nouveaux
produits ce qu'une marque
il peut avoir des vins de bonne qualité
un break mais en général lorsqu'une
goutte les vins en vrac normes qualifie
l'hiver on peut remédier au moins 20
correct un vin est bon vin très bon en
vrac c'est rare qu'on dépasse le correct
ya 30 ans qui est en épicerie puis je le
gêne pas pour le dire c'était vraiment
pas fort mais d'après françois chartier
les choses changent
la science du vin permet une meilleure
compréhension de la culture davin
l'incompréhension de la fermentation
d'élevage de mise en bouteille et tout
ça et même les vins qu'on transporte en
bateau qu'on amène des combats en
bouteille au québec n'est pas de raison
que ça soit pas bon mais là et sécu près
d'une centaine de produits sont des vins
en vrac tout comme 50% des vins vendus
dans le monde
le vrac c'est quoi c'est que ça fait
baisser la facture tout simplement
donc quand tu contrôles en vrac moi je
fais on fait le vin avec trois
homologues
ok là bas je le déguste fait le contrôle
la qualité c'est filtré via un tuyau et
on le met dans une poche sous vide dans
un conteneur qu'on amène ici sert
déguster refile très et en bouteille au
québec
moi ça réduit la facture énormément pour
le transport et c'est écologique
vraiment ça crée des emplois ici des
gros embouteilleurs qui sont là depuis
longtemps mais ils ont peu joué ou si
c'est comme des épices et s'ils veulent
que des jantes en a mais qui prend des
bouteilles il faut qu'ils devront jules
en bouteille et jean ils savent très
bien que ce qui est mon cas ce qui est
beau monde
ils ont compris des gens nouveaux
d'alimentation s'ils veulent garder
leurs clients captifs puis le client
quand cielo il veut acheter son pain
sont les saucissons sont ils des trucs
de bas puis allez dans une épicerie fine
d'acheter ses fromages et charcuteries
et viandes son gibier c est pourquoi ils
ne pourraient pas l'acheter alors ils
ont compris ce sont des grandes surfaces
8000 épiceries dépanneurs au québec et
versus 400 et 5 eu des vins qui sont
donc facilement accessibles partout en
province
quand on est mal pris
l'un des plus serrés
mais à quel prix un exemple le vin rouge
et alliés vivere de but à la saq
la bouteille est vendu 13 de leurs 35
taxes incluses
chez iga elle vous coûtera 13 dollars 99
plus taxes au prix régulier puis quand
vous voyez les prix ici est ce que vous
êtes consciente qui va avoir les taxes
d'ajouter à la caisse
oui on essaye de parler d'économie que
harry j tu vois un bon vin puissent pas
prendre le même vin mais tu vas payer à
taxer le strip au naturel
le prix final dans ce cas la caisse via
la taxe est censée nous déstabilise
c'est que les épiciers ne peuvent pas
vendre moins cher qu est là et c'est qu
ils se prennent en plus une marge de
profit des discussions se poursuivent
toujours entre la saq les embouteillages
et les épiceries pour assouplir
davantage les lois existantes
[Musique]